[Music]
crashing through the crowded halls
dodging girls like ping pong balls just
to reach the bathroom on time that's the
life of the loud house everybody makes
mistakes and this popular Nickelodeon
show isn't any difference from
dislocated shoulders to invisible tapes
check out these animation errors if
you're new here hit that subscribe
button to never miss another video and
don't forget to give us a big thumbs up
let's check out ten animation errors in
the loud house cartoon Anatomy the loud
houses team got better at animation
after a few seasons but you can probably
spot a lot of mistakes during the first
few episodes this one is pretty
frightening especially since the entire
episode revolved around the loud family
being left in the dark after a power cut
this episode introduced us to the family
and gave us a quick insight into the
personalities of all 11 loud children
the first episode starts off with
Lincoln who wanted to watch his favorite
TV show but couldn't because of the
power outage after a few tries of
getting back the power
Lincoln failed and eventually the kids
become scared they have to go to the
scary basement to turn on the circuit
breaker and when they arrive things are
definitely spooky after some typical
sibling taunting the twins Lana and Lola
actually becomes scared and screamed
that there's a ghost in the basement pay
attention to how they look as they both
yell and panic at the same time we're
not sure whether this is an actual
mistake or just some weird cartoon
Anatomy but there's something strange
going on with both of their arms it
looks like their shoulders aren't
connecting to the rest of their bodies
Lola's shoulders definitely look like
they're just an extra set of arms
without any fingers strange right hey
guys the arts
excited to announce we are producing our
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best DIYs fashion tips
makeup hacks and so much more
we are sure you're going to love it and
be sure to let us know what you think in
the comment section you lefty hear from
you see you there the clothing the first
episode is definitely the one that
introduces us to the family we get to
know the kids personalities and we can
immediately tell who's the Brainiac and
who's a total fashionista but there's
another character that changed her style
as the episodes went on Lisa's fashion
definitely isn't as advanced as Lenny's
but she does have a unique sense of
style and how could you not love those
big round glasses she's adorable but
something changed about Lisa since the
first episode left in the dark is the
only episode where you can find Lisa
wearing different clothing her sweater
is actually dark green and it definitely
stands out from the crowd
watch the episode again and pay
attention to the color of the sweater
the contrast of the green color is much
brighter you can definitely see this as
the kids all watch TV now look at some
of the other loud house episodes do you
see the difference
Lisa's green turtleneck sweater is toned
down this could be a simple drawing
mistake as we don't see the same color
again and any of the episodes but it
could also be something the team noticed
and decided to change the color as far
as we're aware this didn't happen to any
other lab house character make sure to
let us know if you've ever seen any more
change in anyone's clothing a chipped
tooth even though the loud house
features 11 siblings the cartoon
revolves around the middle child Lincoln
is the only boy in the family and his
job is definitely not an easy one we
absolutely love his adventures but
what's even more entertaining is
noticing how many times Lincoln changed
his look of course it wasn't his fault
this was a simple animation mistake that
could happen in any TV show but Lincoln
is the only sibling with a chip to so
it's interesting to see
how many times he was seen without it if
you want more examples like this one
make sure to watch the part 1 of 10
animation errors in the loud house there
are a few scenes where you can see the
rest of his teeth clearly outlined but
the one that stands out the most comes
from the second episode of season 1
called get the message in the beginning
of the episode
Lincoln accidentally enters Laurie's
message as he plays it's virtual reality
games Laurie gets angry and Lincoln gets
scared as soon as he realizes where he
is but look at his teeth when he gets
scared
they look perfect don't they we rarely
see his full set of teeth even with his
mouth open as other teeth only seemed to
appear accidentally we can assume this
is a total mistake you can actually see
Lincoln's full set of teeth with no chip
tooth in sight as he's running from his
sisters during the loud house intro a
family portrait
Lincoln definitely doesn't have an easy
life and we get to learn all about his
hectic mornings in project loud house at
the beginning of the episode
Lincoln explains he had to make a report
on his family
it took him three weeks and a lot of
boxes of pasta to make his real-life
family portrait that represents the
chaos of the loud family but it looks
like the animators couldn't decide how
they wanted to portray his project as it
seems to change in every single shot at
sin at the beginning you can clearly
count all eleven siblings and the detail
of the project is amazing but as Lincoln
carefully tries to bring his project
down in the midst of chaos you can see
that the detail on it changes every
single time although you can clearly see
the personalities of each sibling they
look a lot taller when the shot focuses
on Lincoln speaking and again when you
see it from the front but as Lincoln
finally decides to carry the project out
of his room you can clearly see how the
detail of the project changed although
the figures are now shorter you can now
see only eight siblings and they look
absolutely nothing like they do in real
life is it a mistake are just a
simplified animation to save some time
magical cleanup
we all know Lana is a tomboy and she
loves to do just about everything Lola
hates to do this includes being dirty
and not minding having her whole face
covered in mud the two couldn't be more
opposite and sometimes it's really hard
to believe they're sisters although
Lincoln does love them they sometimes
annoy him having one annoying sibling is
enough but having two identical ones is
even harder in a long-term sister
Lincoln brings home a tarantula he knows
that Linney is afraid of spiders so he
only tells his siblings what he's hiding
but then the tarantula disappears after
he puts it in a drawer because it looked
a little sluggish Lincoln panics and
starts searching for the spider the
twins ask him what he's looking for
and Lincoln lies that he found them the
two cutest twins in town and the next
scene the girls realized something is
wrong and confront him Lola points out
that there's no way he'd ever think Lana
is cute as she says it you can clearly
see dirt on long a space including her
cheeks and her hat and when the sisters
are yelling at Lincoln the dirt on her
face disappears completely she either
knows how to clean herself very quickly
like nothing happened or this was just
another small animation mistake another
chip to the loud house isn't just about
Lincoln loud and his siblings we also
get to learn about their friends and the
one that makes a frequent appearance on
the show is definitely Clyde Clyde has a
huge crush on Lori and he can help
himself whenever he's around her he's
definitely adorable and we love his buck
teeth but there's an episode where
Clyde's buck teeth disappear and get
replaced by a chipped tooth similar to
the one you see on Lincoln and get the
message Lincoln got kicked out by Lori
and realized he forgot his gaming
glasses when he goes back to get them he
noticed they were stomped on and
automatically blames Lori as she was the
last person to enter the bathroom in the
next scene Lincoln told Clyde what
happened Clyde is shocked but not
because the glasses are destroyed he
can't believe Lori touched them with her
feet re-watch the scene and pay
attention to Clyde's mouth when Clyde is
totally fascinated by the glasses he has
a chipped tooth just like Lincoln we
usually see him with
teeth as you do in many other scenes
from the same episode maybe he was so
shocked he managed to chip his tooth in
the process
the problem with eyelashes the loud
house characters all have distinctive
features that set them apart from one
another and you might not even notice
some of them we've already outlined some
of these in part one of our video but
there's a specific one that suggests
azar some animators just make new rules
when it comes to cartoon Anatomy we all
know eyelashes go in your eyes but not
this time in toads and Tiaras Lola ends
up getting sick and can't go to the
pageant Lincoln was preparing her for
because he wanted her to win season
passes to Dairyland the entire episode
is absolutely hilarious as we watch Lana
transform into a beauty queen but pay
attention to the beginning where Lincoln
directs Lola's performance and tells her
how much she should smile before she
became ill as she waves look at her
eyelashes as soon as she raises her eyes
her eyelashes look like they're floating
this doesn't happen in any other scene
no matter what emotions she's showing
and neither does it happen to her to win
who ends up being a pretty amazing
pageant queen as Lincoln says those who
scratch lose the match but what happens
to those who suddenly lose their
eyelashes but what do you think was this
an error or was it done intentionally to
highlight Lola's expression let us know
in the comments a strange tongue you
need to be a super fan of the show to
even catch this animation error once you
start noticing all the details you'll
probably be able to catch more and more
animation mistakes we've already
discussed how Lincoln reveals his full
set of teeth with no chipped tooth in
sight and get the message
but there's another animation mistake
you can spot if you pause the episode at
a certain time we all know Lauri doesn't
like it when her siblings butt into her
life and she loves her privacy she also
loves her siblings but most of the time
she tells them what they should and
shouldn't be doing to disturb her and
get the message we see her yelling at
Lincoln after he accidentally walks into
her room with gaming glasses on
pay attention to her tongue when she
yells if you pause it at the right time
you'll be able to see that at some parts
for tongue isn't exactly outlined while
in other parts it totally is let us know
if you managed to catch this one we all
know being an animator is not an easy
job so we're definitely not going to
hold that tiny mistake against the loud
house team although we have to admit her
tongue almost looks human when it's not
outlined we'd probably get scared to a
change of colors the characters of the
show often wear the same clothing as it
highlights their personalities and helps
us telling them apart
Lincoln is almost always seen in an
orange shirt jeans and the same shoes
with three red stripes when he goes to
school he also tends to wear a blue
backpack it's how we know him but
there's an episode out there that shows
Lincoln with slightly different colored
accessories we're not sure if this is a
true animation mistake but make sure to
let us know what you think in the
comments check this out
the episode is called space invader and
as you might have guessed the story
revolves around invading someone's space
after Lin and Lucy have a fight Lincoln
allows Lin to sleep in his room
of course he later regrets that decision
he asks Clyde for advice on what he
should do
Clyde as usual is only dreaming about
War II but pay attention to the scenes
where Clyde and Lincoln are walking to
and from school do you notice something
different about his backpack if you're a
huge fan you probably know that it's
usually blue but looks like the backpack
is brown for these two scenes it's
either an animation mistake or the
backpack was a hand-me-down from one of
his sisters invisible tapes having a lot
of siblings can be a nightmare and it
sure looks like that way for Lincoln who
is trying his best to live with ten
sisters we feel you buddy here's another
example of either a simple animation
mistake or just a simplified version
that makes the animators life much
easier you decide in the comments what
you think about this one it belongs to
the episode called intense debate where
the family is trying to decide on their
destination for their vacation while
half of the family wants to go to Dairy
land and
to the beach Lincoln still not decided
on his preferred destination and asks
for one more day and in true loud house
style.the sabotaging begins the next day
when Lincoln rushes to the bathroom he
finds the toilet completely covered in
tape and a sign saying that the ride is
temporarily closed but rewind the
episode back to when Lincoln first
rushed into the bathroom and you'll see
that the toilet doesn't have any tape at
all so even if Lucy was the last one to
go in there was no way she could have
taped the toilet we're pretty sure the
animators just wanted to make the
element of surprise by not adding the
actual state of the toilet in the scene
but it's still an animation mistakes
poor Lincoln that did 4:10 animation
errors in the loud house for more videos
like this one check out 10 loud house
characters all grown up see you next
time
[Music]